popcorn it's not just limited to movies
though it's sort of one of my favorite
snacks in the world I like it just
normal no butter no like just just a
normal popcorn It's gotta be hot that's
the main thing I will get nacho cheese
and dip my popcorn in it I'm not afraid
of that oh okay large popcorn feel
better you know like the fake butter
that they pump on there you can ask for
real butter popcorn
if it's dry popcorn it's clean look at
that I can touch my pants and there's
nothing there but somebody introduced me
to popcorn and raisin nuts if I'm like
really feeling myself you take like a
handful of both and you just Chomp it
all up together and it's
go to movie snack is Eminem's with
popcorn
a sweet and salty that sticks around on
your behind
but it's worth it it's so good I love
raising it and I Love Popcorn I straight
up have a large popcorn and it is always
done about Midway through the second
preview I agree I'm like just my lips
are chapped it's not open like I'm like
what did I do this is the movie I'm like
it's gone I'm so thirsty yeah it's like
I'm in a contest and I'm gonna win I'll
get like four popcorns sweet and Salted
Popcorn although in the states it's more
butter here isn't it I'm gonna like
speak to the UK and see if they can just
like ship all of their popcorn sweet
popcorn they always eat popcorn and I
always get the large and no I don't end
up sharing it and I get a big big tub of
popcorn buy the 40 popcorn
thank you